what's up it's your girl erica banks
check out my interview right here right
now on the bootleg calf show
yo bootleg cab show special guest her
name is erica banks yeah
yes it is what's going on you just
referred to yourself as the bag lady
i am you've been grabbing a lot of bags
during the pandemic i have
um congratulations by the way that chain
is what does that say
ebanks ebay okay okay how much that
thing run you if you don't mind me i'm
not trying to be in your pocket so i'm
trying to be in your pockets your house
my house i live in
i live in burbank oh that don't mean
nothing to her
it's your house this is
um the craziest thing about busset is
it's a song that was out for a while
right um because i remember hearing
about the song i feel like in the
summertime like maybe june or some [ __ ]
like that
yeah it was um and then it just all of a
sudden
it was just everywhere every goddamn
tick-tock the challenge started going
crazy
yeah it's a perfect example of somebody
who like like you never
if you if you know you gotta hit record
you just keep working it
right because i feel like some artists
would like if a song came out and it
don't hit in the first like month or two
there's like to be like i'm over there
just put something out
that's new that's how i typically go but
sometimes you have to keep promoting
that record because it can do
what mine did you and you knew that this
was like out of here
uh when i seen it do what he did on tick
tock i knew it was that okay okay oh
yeah
you heard a lot of knees you know that
with that song a lot of auntie knees was
yeah that was in there did you see the
x-rated joints
oh i did i did yeah there was a
chocolate girl on there that was it
now when you know that you're like the
inspiration behind a challenge like the
busted challenge right this is a this is
a challenge that
uh everyone's done right right who's
like been who is the biggest person that
did it where you were like oh [ __ ] that
person did the budget challenge
you know what it was it was two
different people it was tracy ellis ross
and it was gabrielle union yeah yeah
yeah it was epic
i was like what is going on but it was
live it was real loud to see
yeah like you you had you had like
little like 13 year old girls out here
busting it down younger than that
i've seen like jesus yeah does that does
that like territory
like like like no it doesn't it
encourages me to keep making music
fire let me ask you this
texas is known for like amazing
hip-hop right right but you're from
dallas
right which is an area that recently has
gotten a lot of notoriety
but like overall in the grand scheme of
things has kind of been slept on
in the hip-hop community you know
there's guys like darrow and right you
know there's been some dope guys out of
dallas but
houston gets all the love all the
attention yeah um
do you feel like is there like a chip on
your shoulder coming out of dallas
not at all not at all and i say that
just because
i came out of dulles you know like it
happened for me so i don't feel any way
or
you know have a chip on my shoulder you
know it just takes the right kind of
artistry
to get out you know right and you've
been doing this since she was 22 right
you just
started like three four years ago yeah i
started when i was 19. i'm 22 now
and you killing it came out with the
child congratulations congratulations
some people were doing it for 20 years
can't get nowhere close like this
yo facts um yeah
when it comes to the dallas thing if
you're from dallas are you automatically
a cowboys fan
uh me i'm not even into sports good
because
my least kind of favorite human being in
the world is a dallas cowboys fan
oh okay not too much though no no i just
can't stand these cowboys fans
they're probably the most delusional
group of human beings ever assembled in
the world they're a little raggedy
they're good
they look raggedy bro no no no your
city's great it's just the people who
roof your football team
they're delusional super delusional like
you're not going to do nothing next year
let me ask you this okay you know how
lakers okay come on
i'm i'm from arizona so listen my teams
are not yeah i don't have any rings so i
have no way to talk
okay so dallas fans are like the
trump supporters of sports right oh wow
they like can't admit that it's over
like oh yeah you got it on
we still got it like it's been it's been
i was four years old
anyway i i digress you're not into
sports nah
um what are you into what are you doing
your free time in my free time
i like to shop i like to draw clothes
i'm into fashion
so you draw you like design your own
clothes and stuff i like to do that yes
i have before i've done three places
do you have aspirations to uh like start
your own clothing line and i do
i want to open my own clothing store i'm
actually into nails too like long nails
and
i normally have them all when i took
them off yesterday they kept hurting but
uh i want to open up a nail shop so i'm
really just into the fashion world and
i always wonder this right because when
you have certain like nails that have
you just wrap it around the finger all
the way you know
and it just seems like it'd be harder to
do like
some things like i know like like do you
play video games with nails that long no
it's not it makes it harder right it
does yeah he ain't had no black aunties
you know none of that
that's why i started explaining i knew
where he was going with it i was trying
to explain
just easy wrap around you gotta bend
over a little bit more but that's it
but just wrap it it's possible but some
girls be
oh you're talking about wiping i wasn't
even going there without you okay
but i appreciate that she caught it i
thought that's what she was talking
about
hey i wasn't even [ __ ] asking but now
we know so you wrap it around
yes you use more toilet paper than a
normal
yes so you're oh i got you yes so the
pandemic was a little rougher for you
because it was kind of it was it was
hard to find a house paper
per day like oh yeah two rolls a day i
mean when you
what are you eating i mean two rows a
day i'm not the only one
right right right you don't live alone
she's trying to take that back
it's two you you're doing two rows by
yourself no no no no
yeah that's crazy um a good homie of
mine uh yellow bees is from dallas right
um
who's you know there's there's a whole
new wave of dallas artists uh
you guys got a relationship we do we
actually have a record out uh we just
dropped the video it's his record that
i'm on called star
uh we put it out a few weeks ago he's
doing really well and
everybody's liking the song so yeah nice
who's got the better strip clubs because
i've been to strip clubs in both cities
dallas or houston
houston for show i'm going to say it's
got to be houston right now yeah it's
definitely
we're going to find out if
and i'm gonna i'm gonna atlanta they're
not playing it they're not playing that
at all
and by the way if you go to atlanta and
you go to uh magic city
the hot wings are overrated oh for sure
they're so
small right this is true hey hey hey
hey people from atlanta will tell you
this killer mike told me this
i went and saw killer mike in atlanta
and i was like dude i went to magic city
last night and then we would
whatever maybe you and i was like you
should have went to blue flame he's like
no he's like magic city's
wings are yeah yeah
it's definitely the truth so you know
something okay um
you know every time this around this
time of year we you know there's the
double excel freshman talk
right is that something that you have
aspirations to try to get on a cover
like that isn't something you don't know
definitely i'm definitely into that um
even before i
had busted blow up i was always
wondering like i wonder how you do that
or i wonder like
you know will i be on that i want to be
on that like so yeah that's definitely
something i want to do
who else would who else in your opinion
should be on the cover with you
for this go around i would say corey ray
hartfordshire's fire yeah um who else is
just kind of coming out right now i
can't think right on top of my head down
maybe freddy freddy okay you know
freddy's been going yeah
uh money move i would say money move
yeah fujiano
uh yeah just the name of you i would say
them i mean i love that money move song
have you ever had it
i was in vegas eating mushrooms like a
month ago
right and i played that song like 30
times in a row and i was just like
[ __ ] i was like a zombie bro why was
you eating mushrooms though
you never had mushrooms just raw uh no
like you know like the
you get high off them oh lord okay
magic mushrooms the magic ones okay i
know he's not just picking up dried
mushrooms
i'm talking about like farmer's market
like like a roush i like about my pizza
i had a poor idea portobello filled with
cheddar i do put them on my pizza okay
you've never had shrooms never never
you'll be seeing stuff yeah
i think edibles are better though
edibles are definitely better do you
like edibles i love edibles oh then
you'd like shrooms do you have some
edibles
i got you in that bag i got you some
whole chocolate bar okay
yum yeah
[Laughter]
now have you ever had a bad edible
experience i haven't actually
i haven't i've never had a bad edible
experience like you've never taken too
much
and just been like [ __ ] stuck no but
i never do eat the whole thing though
i was like share it with a friend or
something that's fair too you know you
know your limits
i do you know you don't go in there like
oh i could take all this oh no no no i'm
not one of those i'm going to take heads
that's how i was
that's how i was the first time that's
how you missed that i'm a big guy i
thought i could
take the whole brownie like there's
nothing okay you are right i was stuck
but now you know yeah i do what is uh
what's next for you
next for erica banks uh we're getting
behind tooth that that'll be the next
thing
i saw you say that it's supposed to be
it's supposed to be bigger it is let's
be bigger
okay yeah so stay tapped in
i'm not gonna say too much about it but
um we do uh have a remix in the works
and we just gonna you know refresh the
record and just get behind it and
do what we did with buses so we can have
that going crazy too travis scott
uh hopping on the record was that like a
you know he's like i always tell
everybody
nobody's infiltrated the mount rushmore
of rap for like a decade
it was like always like j cole kendrick
drake and kanye right and travis scott
just
jumped up on that [ __ ] man you
think he there now of course
nobody got the kids like him pause but
like like literally like
like he's the co he's he's the coolest
[ __ ] rapper that's ever lived
yeah you're right yeah you know what i'm
saying like
yeah so that like that had to be [ __ ]
it was it was it actually came to me as
a surprise i didn't even know that
that was going on or happening um i kind
of was just played the record somebody
played it for me as a surprise like
listen to this
and i hear him come on and i'm like i
know it's not travis scott
you know and it was um but he said you
know as far as him doing the verse he's
just been seeing me do my thing
and he just really likes that i just
been going hard and you know he
respected so
he decided to get on the record that's
dope man that yeah that that's a
milestone right there
yeah who is somebody who you want to
work with uh
in the future that you haven't yet to to
to collaborate with
um i always say nicki minaj in future i
always say them
nikki's the ghost she's the greatest for
sure for sure yeah
easily top of my in my top five easily
growing up as like a a fan of nicki's
did that like inspire you to make sure
like your pen game is like a female
rapper was sharp absolutely absolutely
nikki man she
she's murdered like eminem on song she
murdered jj
connie and ross on monsters oh man yeah
nicki's
roman reigns and she's like yeah
favorite the whole
animation the personality yeah
eminem stop bringing do you have any
other personalities that we that we
don't know about
actually i don't um i don't call them
personalities i have other
voices or tones rather but i wouldn't
okay okay okay okay
now voices in your head though not
voices in my head
what do you watch on tv like what do you
binge watch you know what i don't even
really watch too much of tv
i don't ever really have time and when i
do have time to lay down it's
like at night and i'm just tired so and
i spend a lot of time on my phone so i'm
on my phone you'll be on tick tock
swiping huh
yeah or instagram man you get stuck on
tick tock
easy every [ __ ] night next to me just
[ __ ] tick-tock it and i know
yeah it's between that oh another world
on there it's just
the content they throw at your face is
amazing sometimes like the bus like
like girls busting it oh yeah that's all
that's crazy
i was on my phone and and i'll be with
my girl
and like i'll be on the couch across and
then when you hear that song playing
right
yeah who are you looking at no there's a
hulk there's a whole challenge to that
who the [ __ ] is that who's
she got ain't busting it on the screen
she's trying to see what you saying like
that's awesome yeah yeah
look at you my fiance don't be trippy
she but let me see oh [ __ ] she's doing a
damn thing
okay no my girl's she's a very
uh jealous mexican woman oh
lord he just gonna put on the spot okay
i see i'm the fat guy
with a bad chick so she knows she got me
i'm the fat guy with a bad chick as well
okay she's not worried about that okay
she's like you ain't going nowhere you
lucky to be here [ __ ]
i filmed her buster challenge oh yeah
oh i you were in vegas right yeah yeah
i literally was all like you know baby
you gotta bust it just a little bit more
harder for the viewers
you gotta show me that when we get done
we did two we got one where i made fun
of it then another one where
she did it for her yeah show me about
the i need to see is there going to be a
tudor challenge
actually yes there's definitely going to
be that um i actually
did tick-tock today before i got in here
oh wait can we see it
that's why i want to i just want to know
you know how do you
how do you go about making the
challenges like how do you know which
one i got a tick tock
consultant i actually just took pieces
from my
uh show set that i do
i just put it together okay a little bit
of that
because you seen you seen jlo tried to
start a challenge and it literally
nobody did it
oh wow maybe one and a half people
see these are all these are all very um
if you're white you could do this
i could pull all that [ __ ] off you can
do a little bit of this
little sliding no some of those stick
dot dances are only hands
only arms like that breaking it down
you're gonna get shoulder arthritis the
way you're doing that
um do you have like a i'm assuming
there's a project coming soon
yes there will be a project coming soon
uh when we don't know but we always
have me record music and you know we
steady stacking music so
hopefully by the summertime we'll be
getting ready to put out a project are
there any features that you have tucked
at the moment
there are um yes they are they are it
might be a favorite artist i don't know
well my favorite artist is freddy gibbs
i doubt that oh freddy you know what
nah you're doing some [ __ ] with gangsta
gibs every kind of fire i mean he's
nominated for a grammy on sunday when he
come out
mm-hmm what did your date come out
freddie gibbs yeah uh
like 2010 oh okay oh nine i mean he's
got a grammy nomination sunday
okay that's lit though he's on the
ground he's all he lit he can wrap his
ass off
okay i'm gonna have to check him out we
were in austin he was i was doing
mushrooms with him in austin two weeks
ago
okay so you know it was a good time well
i'm glad
i'm glad y'all had a good time so who so
who's nicki minaj
so you said nicki minaj is on the album
i did say nick when i was on the album
and um she's actually on track number
two i'm just trying to do reverse
psychology with you right now i'll see
what you did
i just went with it and where the [ __ ]
is that you broke it
i thought you broke it okay oh [ __ ] that
worked i'm about to tweet it okay
look why don't you introduce uh
introduce let's
let's have her introduce both songs for
when yeah when you guys start pushing
because busted is still a single right
yeah all right introduce busset right
here on the bootleg cav show
and then we'll we'll do another so this
is the drop
yeah just yeah let's get into the
[ __ ] song let's do it okay yeah
do i need to look at the camera i mean
you can you yeah look at that one right
there
okay what's up it's your girl erica
banks and here is my hottest single
right now it's going crazy it's all over
the world
busy